hey guys it's max welcome to my ultimate
camera comparison between
the iphone 12 pro max the iphone 12 pro
and the standard iphone 12 and we're
gonna find out if it's worth paying the
extra price
for the iphone 12 pro and the even
higher price
and the bigger size the heavier weight
for the max
model both in video and in photo
let's start out with the sunrise shot
and my goodness the pro max
looks so much better we have a lot more
contrast the flaring is less noticeable
and the sky looks better as well and
here i zoomed in about eight times
to shoot this flag and the 12 pro max
and 12 pro look
very similar the iphone 12 looks
terrible
jumping back into photos i have a
telephoto portrait here which the iphone
12 can't do
and we notice that the pro max we have
less of the background we have more
compression and a lot more texture
on emily's jacket and here's a macro
shot and the 12
pro takes the win it could actually get
the closest because of its two times
optical
zoom and it's the most detailed the pro
max actually looks worse
and i took like five or six shots to
make sure i get a sharp one the iphone
12 with this regular lens it can't get
as close
and back to video this is ultra wide
with 4k
and then we're gonna zoom in to one x
and so far
they look identical switching to the
telephotos the 12 pro
and 12 pro max they look very similar
and
the iphone 12 even though it's digitally
zoomed
it is really hard to see a difference in
a 3x zoom the iphone 12
is now noticeably worse looking but the
12 pro looks just as good as the pro max
even though it is digitally zooming more
so
and now let's go to six times zoom with
the iphone 12 can't do so i'm going to
digitally crop it in
and now we can finally tell that the pro
max looks better
but not by that much and the pro max can
go to seven times digital
zoom so just a little bit more than the
pro and here's a standard shot up on a
mountain pass
and all the images look identical and
here's another standard shot but i focus
on my truck to see if we get any more
natural
blur because of the larger sensor on the
pro max but i can't tell any difference
zooming into five times the iphone 12
definitely looks worse
but i'm surprised how close the pro and
the pro max are
and here's a standard portrait shot of
this llama or
emu i'm not really sure but they all
look very similar
and here's a zoom shot of these ducks i
could definitely tell that the iphone 12
looks worse even on phones but the 12
pro
is so close in terms of detail to the 12
pro max
that you wouldn't be able to tell a
difference we have another portrait shot
using the standard
lens and the pro max has less contrast
and more flaring at this angle jumping
to an
ultra wide it is weird to see that on my
6k display
the pro max actually looks slightly
sharper even though these lenses are
identical on all of these
iphones and just to test i shot another
set
with the ultra wide lens and once again
the pro max looks to be applying
a little more sharpening than the other
two and here's a standard
one times photo and here i don't see any
difference in terms of
sharpness and if you guys want to see
the difference in zoom we have
iphone 12 at 1x iphone 12 pro at 2x
and then 2.5 x for the 12 pro max so you
can get a little bit closer without
having to do digital zoom
here's another shot of natural blur
using the standard
lens the 12 pro max has a much larger
sensor so i expected a good amount more
blur but in reality
it is so similar to the other two
iphones here's an ultra wide shot
shooting against the sun with harsh
shadows and what really surprised me
is that the iphone 12 pro max looks the
worst
in terms of processing jumping to the
standard lens the iphone 12
kept glitching out on the auto focus and
i was going to exclude this but this
happened to me multiple times and it
required a restart for some reason
now as far as the 12 and pro max and 12
pro i think the 12 pro looks better
and then zooming in all the way the 12
per max gets closer but it doesn't look
better than the 12
pro it looks worse because of contrast
and a little more noise
and now for a sunset shot once again
we get more flaring on the 12 pro max so
it looks like if you're shooting at a
downward angle
it is noticeably worse than the 12 and
12 pro
and now let's compare the stabilization
i left out the 12 because it has the
same exact setup as the 12 pro
the 12 pro max has that sensor shift
stabilization
and i set both these phones horizontal
and i'm holding them with a special
handle and the results are very
similar they're both extremely good this
is at 24 frames per second
so you do have a little bit more motion
blur but i can't really tell the
difference
and here's a zoomed in shot using the
telephoto lenses and i'm walking of
course it looks terrible here because of
how zoomed in i am
i will say the 12 from max's 2.5 times
optical zoom looks slightly
steadier but not by much i want to do
another test in terms of background blur
but this time with video i'm very close
to this object here
so this is natural blur and man the
results are almost
identical i was expecting more
background blur from that larger sensor
in the 12 pro max
and here's a telephoto shot it is kind
of getting dark now
and man the 12 pro's telephoto actually
looks
better we have more detail less noise
and slightly better stabilization for
standing still
and hand holding the phones and now
let's jump into night shots and don't
let this photo fool you it was extremely
extremely dark here
the 12 hour max looks slightly better
because of its larger sensor but it is
so extremely close jumping to a
nighttime
portrait you can see that the iphone 12
can't do this because it misses
lidar the iphone 12 pro max looks
slightly better than the 12 pro
jumping to the telephoto lenses the 12
per max and 12 pro could not do portrait
mode because it was just simply too
dark but the 12 pro max did get a better
looking image
and now we have a telephoto night time
shot and the 12 pro and the iphone 12
actually look better than the 12 pro max
even the iphone 12
is digitally zoomed in now that is
because the iphone 12 pro max
takes in less light into that more
zoomed in telephoto and here's an indoor
low light zoom shot at 3x
the 12 pro max looks actually slightly
worse than the 12
pro because it takes in less light even
though 12 pro is more digitally zoomed
and the iphone 12 of course
looks by far the worst jumping to the 1x
standard lens though with night mode the
12 pro
and iphone 12 actually look better than
the pro max for some reason which turned
out kind of flat
and now for extreme low light i could
barely
see here the 12 pro max does have the
sharpest image
because of that stabilized sensor in
this shot once again the 12 pro max does
look
better because it has slightly more
stabilized ignore the goat which was
kind of moving around in the other shots
and in this static shot the 12 for max
actually looks slightly worse so that
sensor stabilization doesn't always fix
your issues we have
one more portrait shot this time of my
wife the 12 pro can't do portrait shot
and night mode at the same time the 12
pro can but the pro max
does look the best with slightly less
noise and for some low
light video the 12 pro max is noticeably
cleaner
on my 6k display but when looking at
this
on my phone i honestly couldn't tell a
difference and i was expecting more from
that larger sensor in the max
so what are my thoughts overall well in
certain cases the 12 pro max does do
better but they are in pretty extreme
cases
but in other cases the 12 pro looks
better it's better at
macro shots in low light situations it's
also better with that telephoto lens
letting in more light the video
differences are
very minor and in general i expected a
lot more from the pro max with its
larger
stabilized sensor alright guys thanks
for watching let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below is it
worth spending the money for the 12 for
the extra zoom camera
and the 12 pro for the extra sensor
stabilization bigger sensor things
like that i want to hear your guys's
opinions click that circle above to
subscribe
and check out one of our other great
videos right over there
thank you for watching it's been max and
i'll catch you in the next video
[Music]
you